difficile de circuler
quid stationner sur cette immense
parking de carrère ya plus de 800
voitures qui sont déjà entrés ou
assortie à ses obligés de repousser le
monde convient pas à cette place là le
plus grand parking qu'on allait il n'est
pas encore cette heure et pourtant les
passagers se presse car les places
assises dans ce bus à haut niveau de
service sont rares maintenant que je
suis assise oui après je m'attendais
bête de goût je pensais pas qu'il y
aurait autant de monde donc mais c'est
la preuve que ça fonctionne et je pense
qu'il faudra que mettre plus de
rotations et le pari semble gagné pour
ce premier jour de rentrée générale en
plein pic de circulation c'est-à-dire
entre 6h et 10h les usagers que nous
rencontrons sont majoritairement des
automobilistes qui ont fait le choix
d'abandonner leur voiture pour se rendre
au travail ce matin en déposant la
voiture à carrer ça ne la durée du
trajet est le même mais on arrive moins
stressés au travail à la maison ou au
bureau
donc pourquoi ne pas choisir ce moyen de
transport bon espresso agréable en
voyage climatisé souri aux gens c'est
convivial en plus c'est vrai que le
transport est très agréable bus
climatisé à l'heure donc on est vraiment
ravis d'avoir ce nouveau mode de
transport en martinique
c'est plus intéressant pour moi de
prendre les tcsp le dire le mardi les
autres jours en tant que jeu commercial
je suis sur le terrain c'est plus
intéressant à ce moment de prouver que
même s'il ne s'agit pour l'heure que
d'un ressenti l'engorgement des axes
routiers desservies par le tcsp sont bas
voire nettement diminué si vous compare
à la rentrée générale de 2014 par
exemple un ressenti partagé aujourd'hui
par ce chauffeur
qui est plus rapide qui est plus fiable
pour éviter les embouteillages
de toutes les façons il n'y a que ces
moyens disponibles pour faciliter le
transport des voyageurs en ce moment
jusqu'à maintenant les transports en
commun n'avait pas la cote en martinique
depuis le début des années 2000
leur fréquentation ne cesse de diminuer
au profit de la voiture
reste à savoir alors si la mise en
service du tcsp inversera cette tendance